president trump is furiously denying a
published report that claims he insulted
americans who died in combat
mr trump spoke last night after four
unnamed sources but said to have direct
knowledge told the atlantic that the
president once called u.s service
members
buried in france losers and suckers ben
tracy is at the white house for us ben
good morning to you the pushback on this
story has been uniquely intense hasn't
it
it sure has tony you know when this
report first came out at least 10
current and former trump administration
officials went on the record
strongly denying it and the president
himself looked visibly angry last night
as he denied it
calling it an attempt to influence the
election
and i would be willing to swear on
anything that i never said that about
our fallen heroes
on his way back from pennsylvania the
president denied a new article in the
atlantic
that says in a 2018 trip overseas
president trump questioned why he should
go to a cemetery of american soldiers
near paris
saying it's filled with losers and
called the american war dead
suckers for getting killed there is
nobody
that respects them more so i just think
it's a
horrible horrible thing no animal nobody
what
animal would say such a thing and
especially since i've done more i think
than
almost anybody to help our military
the article also said the president
canceled the visit to the cemetery
because he feared his hair would become
disheveled in the rain
you can also speak to secret service
they wouldn't let me go no matter what
happened
because of security because of safety at
the time the white house did tell
reporters that trip to the cemetery had
been canceled
due to difficulties caused by the
weather but both german chancellor
angela merkel
and french president emmanuel macron
attended a memorial service at other
sites also outside paris
the article also says that when senator
john mccain died
the president told his senior staff
we're not going to support that loser's
funeral
i disagreed with john mccain but i still
respected him
but back in 2015 then candidate donald
trump said this of mccain
who is a prisoner of war for more than
five years in vietnam
he's not a war hero he's awarded five
and a half years he's a war hero because
he was captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
i hate to tell you the latest
controversy comes as the president again
appears to suggest supporters who vote
by mail
should also vote in person sign your
mail and ballot
okay you sign it and send it in and then
you have to follow it
and if on election day or early voting
that is not tabulated and counted
you go vote cbs news has obtained a new
department of homeland security bulletin
that warns russia is amplifying
criticisms of vote by mail
and echoing the president's own words
claiming ineligible voters could receive
ballots
now in many states it is a felony to
knowingly vote twice
on thursday north carolina's board of
elections had to send out a reminder to
voters about that
and told them don't come to the polls in
person if you have already voted by mail
they fear that will make the lines
unnecessarily long and could spread
coronavirus
anthony ben thank you very much